secretary of state anthony blinken
admits americans will be stuck in
afghanistan past the august 31st
deadline and joe biden smirks at
reporters for asking basic questions i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn for peace of mind whenever
you go online visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first here is your quick
reminder if you're not with pure talk
usa you're spending too much money on
your cell phone bill how do i know
because if you're with verizon or att or
t-mobile you're just paying too much by
switching over to pure talk usa your
family could be saving over 800 a year
and you have the same exact coverage as
a t or verizon or x-mobile because
puretalk is on the exact same network as
one of the big three but at a fraction
of the price switching is as easy as
switching out your sim card you can keep
your phone keep your number or get huge
discounts on the latest iphones and
androids plus right now you can get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
for just 30 bucks a month and if you go
over on data they're not going to charge
you for it there's a reason pure talk is
the highest rated wireless company by
consumer affairs why they are the
preferred wireless partner of amac from
your cell phone to alpen250 say ben
shapiro save an additional 50 off your
very first month of pure talk usa
coverage and you're paying all the
overhead for these other big wireless
companies you're also paying for
packages you don't really need instead
get the data that you need and if you go
over on the data you're not actually
going to have to pay for it with pure
talk usa dialpound250 say ben shapiro
get started today and save an additional
off your very first month and hundreds
of dollars down the road that is pure
talk usa okay so remember that time that
joe biden said there there would be no
americans left behind you actually said
there'd be no americans or afghan allies
who would be left behind well all of
that was a lie it continues to be a lie
today but now we have a new line from
the biden administration and the new
line is if you are still in afghanistan
after the us military leaves and
remember we left
basically with no preparation
we had to reinsert troops just to hold
kabul airport we gave up bagram so we
didn't actually have more than one
runway running at the same time we're
not in control of any of the gates at
the kabul airport
the new line from the biden
administration is if because we screwed
up you are stuck in afghanistan it is
your fault and it's on you
this is the new line
right so long suckers you're on your own
this is the new take from the
biden administration it really is
astonishing
okay like you could see this line
formulating over the past several days
because you saw the language shift from
the administration at the beginning the
language from the administration was we
will get everybody out then it was we
will get everybody out who wants to
leave
right and it was sort of a subtle shift
that not many people noticed who wants
to leave i mean everybody thought okay
well that means everybody i mean who
wants to stay is everybody there like
yeah let's hang with the taliban that's
what i'm in in this game for
but the real
point of that phrase was to create
wiggle room so now
if there is an american or an afghan who
gets stuck in afghanistan the idea will
be that the united states did its best
but these people they were just
intransigent they're probably trump
voters or something they were just stuck
there and they didn't want to leave
those idiots this is the direction that
we are now moving very very very quickly
from the joe biden state department and
from the white house itself and here is
the thing
people are stuck there not because they
don't want to leave but because we are
not competent in getting them out
you're hearing all these big statistics
about 82 000 people have left okay
number one how many of those people are
vetted number two how many of the people
who are leaving are not american
and how many americans are still stuck
there and how many people who want to
get out cannot get out
i'm amazed at the shift in in sort of
direction here from the biden
administration they are captaining the
titanic
they steered the ship directly into an
iceberg on purpose by the way they saw
the iceberg and they ran directly into
it it wasn't like the thing came up by
surprise
they ran directly into the iceberg
because joe biden is a fool and wanted
to run directly into the iceberg and
then as the titanic took on water they
offloaded a bunch of people onto the
lifeboats and then when a bunch of
people drowned and were stuck on the
titanic they as the captain of the
titanic they said well you know we did
run a historic effort to get people off
the titanic and onto the lifeboats in
fact guinness book of world records more
people have been put on lifeboats today
than have ever been put on lifeboats
before so really this is a giant success
hey but it isn't the state department
yesterday was forced to tell people not
to come to kabul airport now remember
the deadline that was set as of
yesterday and was confirmed as of
yesterday was august 31st it is
currently according to my calendar which
is reliable august 26th that means five
days until we hit the deadline and it's
going to take at least 72 hours for us
to pull out the remaining troops which
means that if you work backwards and we
still don't know whether it is noon on
august 31st or if it's midnight on
august 30th or if it's midnight on
august 31st we don't know okay but let's
assume that it's the very it's 11 59 pm
august 31st
this means that we have to remove our
troops as of august 28th so basically we
have today and then two more days and
that's it
we have two or three days maximum to get
more people out
yesterday was completely lost because
the state department was getting threats
from isis because isis is in town and
the taliban are providing a very bare
bones level of security unbelievably
enough for americans to get out
presumably because we're bribing them
and that bare bones level of security
does not apply to afghan nationals who
are being stymied and held up and many
american citizens can't get in either
according to the state department
yesterday they told people to go home
there are no more flights coming after
probably april 20 after probably august
28th august 29th certainly not after
august 31st and the state department put
out a statement yesterday quote due to
threats outside the kabul airport u.s
citizens should avoid traveling to the
airport and avoid airport gates unless
you receive instructions to do so those
at the abbey gate eastgate or northgate
should now leave immediately
so if you are stuck outside the airport
they're telling you now to go home the
state department
and wait for us to leave
meanwhile anthony blinken the state
department secretary he says there might
still be 1500 americans in afghanistan
i'm not sure where they're getting these
numbers because remember every estimate
up until the last 48 hours was that
there were 10 to 15 000 americans in
kabul
tony blinken and the rest of the team
over at the state department have now
said that we've gotten out about 4 500
americans
so if he says there are 1500 americans
in afghanistan still
plus the 4 500 who have left that's only
6 000.
what happened to the other somewhere
between 4 and 9 000 americans did they
never exist
where are they getting these numbers are
they artificially lowering the numbers
so that americans don't know how many
americans are stuck there are we
abandoning more people in afghanistan
than died on 911 to the tender mercies
of the same people
who protected the 911 terrorists
that is quite possible given the
statistics put out by this government
here's anthony blinken saying there
could be 1500 people still stuck in
afghanistan who are american citizens
starting on august 14 when our
evacuation operations began
there was then a population of as many
as 6 000 american citizens in
afghanistan who wanted to leave
over the last 10 days
roughly 4 500 of these americans have
been safely evacuated along with
immediate family members
over the past 24 hours
we've been in direct contact with
approximately 500 additional americans
and provided specific instructions on
how to get to the airport safely
okay and uh and then we told them that
they can't get in because there's too
much of a threat outside the gates so go
home again that analysis has shifted
somewhat remember the number was ten to
fifteen thousand americans now anthony
blinken is saying six thousand americans
and there's that magical language right
who wanted to leave there's a population
of six thousand american citizens in
afghanistan who wanted to leave so are
you saying that there are another 9 000
american citizens in afghanistan who
didn't want to leave or like this sounds
great i'm sticking around for the 8th
century goat herders and barbarians to
come in and rape my wife and then shoot
me in the face hey where did these other
people go
where is the evidence that they didn't
want to leave
like where is this coming from
the answer is it's coming from covering
their asses they have to cover their
asses they're abandoning people there
they know they're abandoning people
there and so they got to use whatever
tactics are available to pretend this
isn't one of the great debacles in
american foreign policy history
meanwhile john kirby over at the
pentagon he's like we don't know how
many americans are in afghanistan so
blinken is telling you right now it's 6
000 americans who were in afghanistan we
got 4 500 out there 1500 left over we're
working on them john kirby has asked how
many americans are in afghanistan he's
like
i think yesterday you did put out a
statement saying about 4 000 americans
have been evacuated that's correct um is
there an updated number and do you have
the sort of base number how many have to
be evacuated now it's uh right now today
north of 4400
um and i don't uh i don't i don't have a
specific
uh number of total uh americans that uh
that are still
in need of of uh of leaving i don't have
that
[Music]
oh so we yeah so who do you believe tony
blanken or john kirby or none of them
i mean at this point i think none of
them would probably be the correct
response
blinking himself is blaming americans
for not leaving sooner
right he said that uh we are attempting
to get people out but if if you don't
you know if you don't leave we're just
going to assume you didn't want to leave
here's anthony blanken
we're on track to complete our mission
by august 31st provided the taliban
continue to cooperate
and there are no disruptions to this
effort
the president has also asked for
contingency plans in case he determines
that we must remain in the country past
that date
but let me be crystal clear about this
there is no deadline
on our work to help any remaining
american citizens who decide they want
to leave to do so along with the many
afghans who have stood by us over these
many years and want to leave and have
been unable to do so
that effort will continue there's no
deadline every day
past august 30. the effort's going to
continue every day guys i mean we're
gonna leave and we're not gonna have any
soldiers on the ground
we're not gonna have any embassy staff
on the ground we're not gonna have
anybody on the ground but after we leave
i promise we will be working every day
thoughts and prayers to the people stuck
on the ground in kabul from tony blanken
right there you know
we're out i mean we're gone but don't
worry we're working every day by ask by
sending engraved invitations to the
taliban to let you out that's what we'll
be doing
every single day we will be getting on
tv and talking about how mean the
taliban are and how they have to make
existential choices about who they want
to be
and then we'll send them really nasty
letters from the u.n maybe if russia and
china allow us
i mean what a plan that is big you know
what have been useful about this point
when you think about it what could have
been super useful at this point is like
a skeleton crew of maybe 2 500 american
soldiers holding all the major cities in
afghanistan along with an afghan
military several hundred thousand strong
backed by superior american might and
technology holding the country if people
wanted to leave you know that would have
been useful
but i understand we had to pull out it
was it was deeply necessary we had to if
we didn't pull out then nothing would
have happened and now something has
happened and so obviously that means we
should have pulled out this is always
part of the plan gang and they have
contingency plans in fact it's like a
stack of turtles it's turtles all the
way down right it's contingency plans
all the way down if this contingency
happens we have another contingency plan
sure all of the plans suck
and sure we caused all of this and sure
we're botching it in real time but the
reality is the people who are to blame
are the people who are still on the
ground stuck in kabul
according to the uk daily mail blink and
blamed americans still on the ground for
not leaving fast enough after first
being warned earlier this year to leave
afghanistan as soon as possible that
said there would be no deadline in
helping those who still want to leave oh
that is some cold comfort he said we've
been reaching out to some americans but
um some americans are not responding so
we'll assume they want to stay lincoln
said what we're doing is very carefully
tabulating everything we have
cross-checking it referencing it using
different databases we'll have numbers
for all those different categories in
the days ahead and after this initial
phase of efforts to bring people out of
afghanistan ends
but the idea is that we've reached out
over and over and over again and if
people aren't responding well there's
not much that we can do okay well
assuming that people are not responding
to your requests and to your letters
does not mean that they actually want to
stay do we know they're not being held
by the taliban do you know they have
access to the internet do you know they
haven't been cut off we don't know any
of those things but this is the new line
the line is if you're stuck in
afghanistan it is your own fault here's
ambassador ross wilson he is the biden
administration ambassador to afghanistan
saying this they're a bunch of americans
and if they're stuck there on them
we put out uh repeated warnings every
three weeks to americans going back to i
think march or april uh each one in
stronger terms leave now leave
immediately uh never in my my
40 years of working
since i began working at the state
department have i seen
such strong such strong language used
uh people chose not to leave that's
that's their business that's their right
uh i i we regret now that that many may
find themselves in a position that they
would rather not be in uh and we are
determined to try to try to help them
[Music]
oh we're determined to try to help them
but you know they didn't respond they we
told them you know what would have been
very helpful is if the president of the
united states last month hadn't told
everyone in afghanistan that all was
well and things were going fine and the
taliban had no capacity to take over the
country
that would have been helpful
it turns out that when you tell people
you know you really should leave it's
very important that you leave now you
need to leave and meanwhile you're like
everything's going to be fine it's going
to get turned over to the afghan
national government they're going to be
fine our intelligence sources say
they're going to be fine this isn't
going to be like saigon
when you give those assurances to people
maybe some of them aren't so fast on the
uptake with the let's get the hell out
of here
okay that is not their fault that is
your fault
the question is are those
are those amer we're not even talking by
the way about the afghans who worked
with us who are giving second and third
priority and those people are just
screwed the taliban's going to come in
and they're going to execute all of them
and and biden originally promised you
can see again how the language shifted
we shifted with americans from we're
getting everybody out to we'll get out
everybody who wants to go to look how
many people didn't want to go amazing
that's what happened with americans with
afghan nationals who are working with
the united states who had special
immigrant visas
with afghan translators the line was
everybody who wants to get out everybody
we can get out we'll get out everybody
then it was we'll get out as many people
as we can then it was well sorry
and the media are already declaring them
you know great at this like you can see
the worm turning with regard to the
media who are starting to move on from
the story and be like well they did get
thousands of people out i mean it is a
world guinness book of world records
record for how many people they're
getting out
but let's be real about this the
evacuation is not under america's
control because we handed over control
of the country to the taliban here's
john kirby from the pentagon saying that
we are in daily communication with
taliban commanders about
who we want to see get in and what the
credentials are what they look like
what's valid uh and that that com that
communication happens literally every
day we have been uh nothing but open
with the taliban about uh who we expect
them to let in uh again
fully recognize that it's uh that uh
that that not every step of this process
is in our firm control
oh it's not in our firm control guys but
and you know what they're saying they're
saying now that isis controls things
it's not even the taliban right the guys
who are even worse than the taliban are
actually in control of our timeline here
at isis we have to leave because we're
afraid that the taliban won't hold back
isis after august 31 we'll get to that
in one second first let us talk about
your personal home security well when
i'm on the road i want to make sure that
everything is hunky-dory at home and
this is why i use my ring alarm security
system i can check what's going on at my
house from anywhere at any time when we
move from california to florida one of
the first things my wife said is let's
make sure that we get the ring devices
on the house and thus we did with my
ring alarm security system i'm at ease
all the time with regard to my home
security protect your home the same way
that i do with ring alarm ring alarm is
a powerful affordable whole home
security system you can easily install
yourself it works seamlessly with other
ring products in one simple app for a
special offer head on over to ring.com
ben it is the perfect way to start your
ring experience keep an eye on every
corner of your house with indoor and
outdoor cams see what is happening
directly from your phone you can protect
your home anytime from anywhere with
ring alarm so go to ring.com you get a
special offer today on a ring alarm
security kit you can build a system
right for your home have it up and
running in just minutes feel safer and
more secure that's ring.com if it's good
enough for my family i can promise you i
think it'll be good enough for yours
ring.com go check them out right now
ring.com slash ben all right so isis is
actually so the bite administration was
like well the taliban is kind of in
charge well now it turns out that isis
is actually kind of in charge according
to the new york times the united states
has been battling the taliban and their
militant partners in afghanistan
al-qaeda and haqqani network for 20
years by the way the taliban are now
providing security for americans at the
airport and sort of the haqqani network
yeah things are going great but the
biggest immediate threat isn't to any of
those people it is islamic state
khorasan or isis-k
the terrorist group's affiliate in
afghanistan it's like special k except
islamic terrorists created six years ago
by disaffected pakistani taliban isis k
has carried out dozens of attacks in
afghanistan this year american military
and intelligence analysts say threats
from the group include a bomb-laden
truck suicide bombers infiltrating the
crowd outside hamid karzai international
airport and mortar strikes against the
airfield
by the way all it takes to end everyone
being able to get out is one mortar
hitting the runway at hamid karzai
international airport when you hear
international airport you imagine like
lax or o'hare
right you don't imagine like a single
runway that's what kamikaze
international airport is it is a postage
stamp because we decided like fools diva
bagram air base
richard engel from nbc news he reported
from afghanistan before any of this went
down and he like went and he was
bicycling around bagram air base there
was no one there he was able to to
look underneath all the trailers he was
able to get into all the storehouses we
just abandoned the place for no reason
at all these threats coupled with new
demands by the taliban for the u.s to
leave by august 31st probably influence
president biden's decision on tuesday to
stick to that deadline biden said every
day we're on the ground is another day
we know isis k is seeking to target the
airport and attack both u.s and allied
forces and innocent civilians which is
of course why the us embassy on
wednesday warned americans to stay away
from the airport completely a senior u.s
official who spoke on the condition of
anonymity to describe confidential
assessments confirmed the us was
tracking a specific incredible threat at
the airport from isis k which has
carried out dozens of attacks in recent
years
the threats lay bare a complicated
dynamic between the taliban al-qaeda and
haqqani network and their bitter rival
isis k and what analysts say portends a
bloody struggle involving thousands of
foreign fighters on both sides
apparently there are eight to ten
thousand members of isis k in
afghanistan
afghanistan has now become the las vegas
of terrorists of the radicals and the
extremists said ali muhammad ali a
former afghan security official people
all over the world radicals and
extremists are chanting celebrating the
taliban victory this is paving the way
for other extremists to come to
afghanistan wait you're telling me that
when we abandon afghanistan it's going
to become wait for it a terror center
for people who hate the united states
and the west and who might perform
terrorists why do we go there in the
first place again anybody can remind me
and joe biden told me by the way last
week that the terror threat in
afghanistan had been quelled so there
was really no reason for american troops
to be there at all oh well well the good
news is that as always this is part of
the plan but it's all part of the plan
isn't it
well jen saki was asked about that like
what's the plan after the deadline you
say you're going to withdraw everybody
by august 31st so what's the plan jen
and her answer was plan we don't need no
stinking plans
we are looking at a range of options for
how we can continue to provide consular
support facilitate departures for those
who wish to leave after august 31st and
our expectation and the expectation of
the international community is that
people who want to leave afghanistan
after the us military depart should be
able to do so we're working on that as
soon as we have more to to provide to
all of you more information we will do
exactly that
okay so as soon as we have a plan that
we just pulled directly out of our asses
then we will get that to you but right
now we don't have a plan beyond that
well the good news is the president of
the united states is also very sanguine
about all of this in fact he's joking
about it so yesterday
peter alexander asked joe biden what he
will do if americans are still in
afghanistan after august 31st his
response quote you'll be the first
person i call
took no further questions
um
so
that is a disgusting response
right a journalist asks the most
straightforward question in the world
what's your plan after august 31st and
he says you'll be the first person i
call
what a
douche i mean seriously
they said that donald trump lacked
empathy the cruelty was the point i'm
not sure what you would say about this
you got thousands of americans who are
stuck in afghanistan
you have
tens of thousands of afghans who want to
get out who are stuck by the way if you
look at the video from like the
pakistani border or the turkish border
you can see that like
it's insane like the turkish are in
control of some of the borders
you can see that it's completely insane
like thousands and thousands of people
trying to get out and no place to go
everybody's trying to escape the
clutches of the taliban and joe biden is
joking well you'll be the first person i
call willy though you wouldn't even call
boris johnson of the g7
right you wouldn't return his phone
calls in the middle of this debacle joe
how bad is this the white house actually
cut the feed of biden i'm not kidding
you the man's not in charge of zone of
his own administration here
you'll hear the clip go silent that's
when the white house actively cuts the
audio feed of joe biden the president of
the united states because they don't
want people noticing that he's a
rambling old idiot
okay so you can hear peter alexander
call out the question and then they just
cut off the feed and then you can see
him mouth he'll be the first person i
call
things are going great guys they're
going great
okay so meanwhile peter ducey actually
asked jen saki about all this he's like
you know joe biden is joking about this
but i've noticed that there's a bit of a
humanitarian crisis on the ground in
afghanistan so what's so funny
at the tail end of the president's
remarks today about cyber security he
was asked about afghanistan and he made
a thing peter asked him that question
the other peter did and he made a joke
so what's so funny
well i think the question he was asked
if i remember correctly was about uh
when he will provide information about a
decision on august 31st i don't want to
paraphrase the question if that was an
inaccurate description of the question a
lot of people watching of course it's a
very important question
okay of course a very important question
but he's just joking about it because he
likes two scoops of chocolate chip ice
cream chocolate chocolate chip that's
his ice cream guys the important thing
is that he slipped while he was chasing
his dog around the bathroom these are
the important things to know about joe
biden meanwhile i've noticed that um
we've also shifted our stance on what
the us military is for and what
america's foreign policy looks like with
regard to terrorists so jensaki was
asked um didn't it used to be said that
we were not in favor of negotiating with
terrorists and aren't you now
negotiating with terrorists and shin
sake he's like well yeah kind of
why haven't we heard the president say
the united states does not negotiate
with terrorists is that still the u.s
policy
well of course it is peter but i would
also say that uh there's a reality that
the taliban is currently controlling
large swaths of afghanistan
that is a reality on the ground and
right now our focus and our priority is
getting american citizens evacuated and
our afghan partners evacuated and i
would say given the numbers that we've
outlined and briefed for you that we've
had made a great deal of progress in
doing exactly that
and we've been we've i mean and so yes i
mean the answer is yes we are
negotiating with terrorists because they
hold the whip hand over us
again there's been a complete reversal
here between the the
sort of
vision of what the american military is
actually for and what democrats
apparently believe the american military
is for democrats in the aftermath of the
vietnam war they said okay we came out
we can't treat the military like garbage
anymore because that was really bad for
us politically so instead we'll treat
the military as though they are victims
and so our sole job is to protect the
military from actually having to do
anything every time there's a foreign
deployment our chief goal
is to
not be in there right we're basically to
make work program according to many
democrats now if you ask members of the
military they're not into it members of
the military know what they signed up
for what they signed up for is to defend
american citizens i can think of no
greater situation requiring military
defense of american citizens than
hundreds thousands of american citizens
stuck behind enemy lines in kabul
probably a hundred yards away from where
the american military sits
i mean typically in american history
this would be a good time for america's
military might to overwhelm the people
who are in the nearby area pick up the
americans and then if you want to leave
you leave
but because the logic has shifted
because in the minds of democrats the
military they would rather sacrifice
american civilians in kabul
than risk american military going out
to save the american civilians in kabul
that's where we're at right now and by
the way the logic is so insane
that we have now come to the point where
the logic was not even are we going to
risk american military lives to save
american citizens in kabul
the logic several months ago was are we
going to leave americans in afghanistan
where their lives are not at risk
or are we going to pull them out in
order to
say that we protected them remember
there have been zero combat casualties
in afghanistan for the united states
since february of 2020 you are
significantly more likely to die as a
cop in chicago than you were to die as a
soldier in afghanistan between february
2020 and today
so
what exactly was the logic and the
answer is there was no logic
it is all pr
and in the end it's about a real
embarrassment that america having a
footprint anywhere and our enemies know
this
and meanwhile we got planes that are
leaving empty from kabul
there's i mean we're trying to get
people out and this was one plane that
just left from kabul
all empty seats completely empty seats
so what is the biden administration
doing well they're torturing people like
eric prince so blackwater founder eric
prince
reportedly was was charging like 6 500
bucks for people to escape afghanistan
and uh and saki decided that it was time
to yell at eric prince i i have a
question
who would you rat let's say that you are
a person trying to escape afghanistan
and here are your choices
either you pay eric prince 6 500 to
leave or you stay those are your choices
there's no third choice where the
american government does its job
who are you angrier at eric prince for
getting you out or the american
government for sucking so much at this
that they couldn't get you out
i love the misdirection here jen saki
ready to unleash the unleash the dogs of
war on eric prince for charging money to
get people out of there
by the way you know who could pay that
bill
these folks we're gonna spend what five
trillion dollars this year
you're telling me that we couldn't spend
we could make a bargain with eric prince
spend five thousand dollars ahead to get
americans out of there
here is uh here's jen saki going after
eric prince anyway
did you comment specifically though on
eric prince i mean he has
already made so much money from the
afghan conflict and now in these sort of
final waning days is
once again
essentially exploiting people
in order to make profit i mean what is
the position of the administration that
this is taking place
as you were offering flags free of
charge
i don't think any human being uh who has
a heart and soul would support uh
efforts to profit off of people's agony
and pain as they're trying to depart a
country and fearing for their lives
i have a question what about what would
you say about a politician who tried to
politically profit off of people's agony
and pain by pulling out 2500 troops for
no apparent reason and leaving a country
of 38 million people to the tender
predations of the taliban as well as
thousands of americans behind enemy
lines what would you say about the heart
and soul of somebody like that
what would you say about the heart and
soul of an administration that is
sending empty planes away from
afghanistan rather than just paying
somebody to get people out of there
what would you say about that
administration
i love the ire that jen saki can muster
for eric prince again it's not a defense
of eric prince
the point here is that gen saki is ready
to go ape
on eric prince meanwhile the
administration she works for is leaving
americans behind enemy lines and then
telling the world it is because the
americans are stupid that they have been
left behind enemy lines
it's unreal
and quite disgusting by the way
currently the united states is
apparently working to locate 24
california students and 16 parents
trapped in afghanistan
this is according to the la times
apparently
these students went to the country to
visit relatives on special visas for u.s
military service the trip was not school
sanctioned
mike serbia and the district's director
of family and community engagement in
kehan in cahoon valley union school
district east of san diego
they said we have a long summer break
nobody knew the extent of what was going
to happen nobody knew it was coming
they're extended families in afghanistan
they wanted to see their family they
went back likely before the troops left
so they could say hello or goodbye one
more time
what wouldn't you do to go see your
family one more time let alone know you
only have a window of time to go see
them
freyjun hassemi an afghan immigrant
community liaison for the school
district told the publication quote the
families go out there for summer break
the only reason they're there is to see
family if you watch the news you see the
airports are really crowded even for
people with passports it's hard to get
to the gates we're trying to help them
as much as possible trying to reach them
trying to contact them the students
range in age from preschool to high
school
the school year began august 17th two
days after the nation's capital of kabul
fell to the taliban
so um probably all the students want to
stay that's that's what i'm getting what
i'm getting from that story is that the
the preschoolers definitely want to stay
and that's why we're just going to leave
them there
by the way
let's assume that the biden
administration
actually intends on trying to get the
americans out of there so what options
are available after the us military
leaves there's only one
and it's abject humiliation and bribery
right it's we send a lot of money over
to the worst people on earth
to allow the americans out which of
course incentivizes terror groups all
over the world to simply take american
citizens hostage
that is what that does
it incentivizes more of this which is
typically why you don't negotiate with
terrorists right that was always what
the phrase was about you don't
incentivize them to do bad things
knowing they can earn concessions from
you
gop representative major
from uh from michigan
he says that the americans who are left
there it's gonna make the iran hostage
crisis look like nothing
we're on the cusp paris of having the
biggest mass hostage situation in
american history it's going to make 1979
and tehran look like a sleepover because
you're gonna have thousands of americans
left behind that the taliban will then
have for leverage when they want
international recognition they want
money they want economic assistance and
they've got a gun to the head of
american citizens because joe biden left
them
okay that's actually representative
michael walt republican of florida who
served in afghanistan in the united
states army
and he is exactly correct about this and
everybody both sides of the owl knows
this is the case
right here is a democratic
representative
chrissy houlihan democrat of
pennsylvania and she says the same thing
she says we're going to leave people
behind remember that time that uh the
slogan was leave no man behind and now
it's just leave people behind and then
blame them
the the utter disgusting
irresponsibility and blame shifting from
this remember that time that joe biden
says the buck stops here actually it
stops at the preschooler from san diego
who's now stuck with the taliban that
preschooler didn't return phone calls
from the state department
effectively what i'm hearing i think
many others are hearing is that we are
making progress in the sense that we're
escalating the number of people we're
able to successfully get out every
single day it increases and that's good
news uh but i do think that it's it is
worrisome as we talked about just now
that we probably won't be able to
accomplish the mission of leaving no one
behind with the timelines that we have
and so i think that the atmosphere and
the mood within the um meeting was
bipartisanly one of encouraging the
president to reconsider that date
[Music]
okay and he didn't reconsider that
democratic representative jason crowe of
minnesota he said the same thing he said
our afghan allies are stuck back there
too
as you look at the new numbers getting
more people on planes getting more
people out how do you assess the
situation right now and what needs to be
done yeah i'm not seeing a scenario
after all the briefings the information
i've reviewed both as a member of the
intelligence committee and the armed
services committee as well as the
congressional wide briefings that we've
received in the last 24 hours i'm not
seeing a path
for us to get out our afghan partners
between now and the end of the month the
numbers just don't add up uh the
security situation is deteriorating it
is getting worse
[Music]
okay so i mean even the democrats are
acknowledging what a disaster this is
admiral james stavridis who of course
served in the uh in the united states
navy and helped to uh to preside over
the afghanistan where he said we lost
it's over we lost and now they're gonna
take hostages
what is it like for you as someone who
has served there and who's commanded
troops to see this dynamic at play after
the taliban was driven out of that
country so quickly
well as we say in north florida
sometimes you got to know the difference
between quitting and getting beat and
what i mean by that is
we have got to
recognize that in this case we have lost
this conflict
we have lost this kind of okay but what
actually we mean that we've lost this
conflict is we we did surrender we
surrendered
that's what happened here by the way the
taliban are going around showing off
american-made arms right now
things are going great
the taliban are apparently uh gearing up
in literally american uniforms carrying
american guns they've got american
weapons all around them they're writing
american humvees according to the
washington post on his tour through the
fallen city of kabul last week taliban
aligned militant khalil haqqani rose to
address a crowd at the capitol's largest
place of worship pool ilkishdi mosque as
he clutched a us-made m4 rifle his
security guards similarly armed were
draped in the us combat aesthetics that
have come to symbolize the last 20 years
of war in afghanistan and iraq sporting
high-cut helmets with night vision
goggle mounts plate carriers and u.s
camouflage patterns the guards looked
like caricatures of the elite troops who
have hunted insurgents in nightly raids
and firefights the bounty of u.s
provided weapons and vehicles long
paraded by taliban insurgents after
capturing or stealing them from afghan
forces has grown to alarming proportions
well beyond the ability of u.s officials
to casually dismiss and while throughout
the war militants prized rifles and
other sophisticated personal equipment
the sudden and stunning collapse of the
afghan military has allowed for armored
vehicles helicopters and a glut of heavy
weapons to be commandeered by militants
now running the country
since 2005 the us provided at least 18
billion to the afghan military for
equipment and transportation and pretty
much all of that is now in the hands of
the taliban so we've got americans in
the hands of the taliban our weaponry in
the hands of the taliban but according
to the democrats this was unavoidable at
least democrats were willing to stand
for the biden administration we'll get
to that in just one second first let us
talk about the fact that you could be
saving a lot of money on your mail this
year so you don't want to go to the post
office and stand in line because why
would you there's really no point post
office is great but you can save a lot
of time by doing all this stuff at home
and save a lot of money as well with
stamps.com you can mail and chip anytime
anywhere right from your computer send
letters ship packages pay less a lot
less with discounted rates from usps and
ups stamps.com saves businesses
thousands of hours and tons of money
every year here at dailywire we've used
stamps.com since 2017. no more wasting
our time stamps.com brings the same at
us postal and ups shipping services
directly to your computer they make it
very easy for small businesses to mail
and ship and again you get big discounts
off of other postage rates like 40 off
usps up to 66 off ups shipping rates
with their switch and save feature you
can quickly compare carriers and find
the best rates every single time so stop
wasting your time going to the post
office go to stamps.com instead there's
no risk with my promo code shapiro you
get a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus free postage and digital
scale no long-term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com click on
the microphone at the top of the home
page type in shapiro that's stamps.com
promo code shapirostamps.com never go to
the post office again already we'll get
to more in just one second first what is
it like to be part of the fastest
growing conservative media company in
the country join us and come find out we
have open positions at our headquarters
at daily wire in nashville tennessee go
check them out right now at
dailywire.com
currently we are looking for a podcast
marketing manager to join our marketing
team if you're somebody with a lot of
experience and passion for growing
podcasts a creative strategic thinker
and a self-starter go apply like right
now we are looking to hire we're also
hiring a web marketing specialist to do
well a bunch of technical stuff at
dailywire.com but seriously if you know
how to optimize a web experience
if you've ever done a b testing if
you're a data loving nerd if you want to
live in nashville this is the job for
you both positions are based in
nashville for in-office work if you
think you're qualified for either role
go apply now to dailywire.com careers
our team is constantly growing so keep
checking that careers page for new
opportunities
also tonight we're going to be talking
about the debacle in afghanistan we're
going to be talking about the rise again
of lockdowns and curfews and mass
mandates in the forever pandemic we're
going to be talking about all of that on
backstage tonight i'll be there jeremy
bourne will be there michael moles matt
walsh andrew clavin we'll all be there
we'll discuss and debate these hot
topics and talk about whatever else is
on our mind i have a feeling it's going
to be a hot one it streams tonight at 7
pm eastern 6 pm central on dailywire.com
and on our youtube channel daily wire do
not miss it now it's no secret that the
truth is hard to come by if you're
listening to the legacy media which is
why we started our newest morning
podcast morning wire it's been topping
the apple and spotify charts since its
recent release it's the only daily news
podcast that values your time and the
truth and while we're working overtime
to bring you the news you need to know
we need your help to keep the facts
trending toward number one so please
subscribe start listening now to morning
wire on apple spotify or wherever you
listen to podcasts leave a five star
review if you like what you hear you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
and meanwhile you have nancy pelosi out
in full full-scale defense for the biden
administration and it was all inevitable
now here's the thing either it was
inevitable
in which case they should have made
better plans or was not inevitable in
which case they got taken by surprise
they want to claim that it was both
inevitable and also they made excellent
plans which begs the question
what's going on over there if it was
inevitable and you made plans why do
things suck so bad
so they're just gonna try to ram through
this cognitive dissonance these mutually
exclusive positions here's nancy pelosi
the speaker of the house saying this was
a tragic situation it was tragic well
how did that tragedy get started and why
is it tragic and what what i've been
told it's a great success so what that
what what is bad that is happening there
i don't know i just don't know
this is
a a tragic situation i've been there not
eight or nine times africa we want to
make sure that there's a big bright
light shining
on afghanistan if they wish to
participate
uh globally in any way
[Music]
oh
so your threat is and the
administration's threat is that if
the taliban turn out to be bad
which i mean that would be weird if they
turned out to be super bad it would also
be really weird if it ended up being a
terror haven oh wait it already is
that'd be strange
so we'll shine our big bright light on
there and then if they do stuff we don't
like you know what we'll do
we'll send them mean letters you know
what we won't do put any boots on the
ground ever again you know what else we
won't do anything useful
what we definitely will do is threaten
them with economic sanctions because
people who have been living in caves for
the last 20 years or so what they are
most afraid of is losing the
conveniences of daily life
if there's one group of people who are
afraid of you cutting off their internet
access it is the taliban
those people cannot go without ebay and
they need their only fans and they need
it right to hell now and if you cut that
stuff off they will immediately start
talking about women women and gender
studies over at afghan university
okay don't worry the the democrats have
placed their ire in all the right places
you have jen saki who's very angry at
eric prince for charging people to get
out of the country
meanwhile the u.s isn't getting people
out of the country at least not all of
them meanwhile nancy pelosi is very
angry who is she angry at she's angry
because there were two congress people
peter major from michigan and seth
moulton from massachusetts who went over
and did an
un
planned junket to afghanistan to see
what the situation is actually on the
ground over there now they did it with a
minimum footprint
they did not take seats away from people
who needed to leave the country
and they came back with some pretty
valuable information because we are
being lied to day by day by the biden
administration so it's pretty i mean you
have congress people do this sort of
stuff all the time right congress has an
oversight function of the executive
branch you have congress people who
routinely travel places to make sure
that things are happening this is why
you have congress people travel down to
the border for example it's why you have
congress people travel over to europe to
make sure that what we say is happening
is actually happening at the white house
level nancy pelosi however is super mad
super angry at seth moulton and peter
major for going over to afghanistan why
because they came back and they told the
truth about what they saw which is that
americans are going to be stuck there
after august 31st here's nancy pelosi
mustering all the ire she can in her
frail brain in order to uh in order to
get mad at the people who are truly to
blame these two congress people
when did you learn that congressman
bolton and congressman meyer traveled to
afghanistan and is that what prompted
your letter instructing members not to
travel to the region it's not just about
them going to afghanistan we're not even
going to the region because there's a
call on our resources diplomatically
politic
militarily and the rest
in the region as well so this this is
deadly serious we do not want members to
go
[Music]
it's deadly serious we don't want
members to go into war zones and we
certainly don't want them checking out
what's happening over there flashback
2007 u.s house of representatives
speaker nancy pelosi's decision to defy
the white house and meet syrian
president bashar al-assad steps up a tug
of war between democrats and president
george w bush over foreign policy
despite bush's admonitions the talks
were counterproductive and sent mixed
signals pelosi on wednesday sat down
with assad accused by washington of
backing terrorism and adding to middle
east instability newly empowered
democrats already doing battle with bush
over who is really the decider on iraq
policy are taking a more assertive role
on foreign policy
so um nancy pelosi you'll recall
actually went over to
syria and hung out with bashar assad who
was just preparing to kill you know half
a million syrian civilians and she did
that without the permission of the white
house so she is a rich one to be talking
about how bad it is for congress people
to descend to a to an evacuation area to
survey the situation and then report
back accurately to the american people
it's all in this direction and here's
the thing
the bottom line here is that in the end
the biden administration knows this is a
debacle they are hoping you forget about
it in the same way that americans forgot
about benghazi in the same way that
americans apparently have now forgotten
about 9 11 they're hoping that americans
just forget about this that by the time
we hit 2022 it won't matter anymore you
will be worried about your pocketbook
you'll be worried about what's going on
with covid you won't be worried anymore
about the thousands of civilians trapped
behind enemy lines in kabul
it just won't be an issue for you the
only way by the way to make it a
non-issue for you is to just ignore
whatever happens over there so if
americans start being tortured and
killed don't look for the biden
administration to do anything more than
shoot a few missiles at camel asses the
same way that
that bill clinton did in the 1990s after
the bombing of our embassies in kenya
and tanzania
led him to basically blow up a supposed
chemical factory in sudan
look for look for the same sort of thing
to happen from now on if americans are
mistreated if things get really
egregious in afghanistan even if
pictures emerge of the taliban
humiliating americans don't look for joe
biden to do anything there anymore he
has to justify the decision he is making
right now this is now the sunk cost and
joe biden is going to continue to engage
in the sunk cost fallacy right the sunk
cost is getting out
that decision has to be made glorious by
joe biden the only way to make that
decision glorious is to suggest that
peace and at least stability now reign
in afghanistan and that there is no
ongoing threat from afghanistan so the
next few years are going to be about joe
biden downplaying any threat from
afghanistan
they're going to be about democrats
pretending that this is a massively
successful airlift they're going to be
about ignoring whatever comes next
afterward or
giving some mush mouth nonsense about
how we are negotiating and we're going
to get our people out eventually and
five years later the people will still
be there and they'll still be held
hostage by the taliban and will still be
covertly giving aid to the taliban and
they're hoping that you forget about all
of this they're hoping that you forget
about the geopolitical consequences of
handing over afghanistan to the taliban
they're hoping you don't notice that
china feels emboldened and starts to go
after taiwan and starts to cut off
shipping lanes in the south china sea
they're hoping you don't notice that
russia is going to start getting pretty
feisty with latvia and estonia they're
there because americans don't care about
foreign policy until they are forced to
care about foreign policy so the next
couple of years at a very minimum are
going to be about making you forget it's
all sleight of hand it'll make you
forget and the press presumably will aid
them in this task by moving on
all they have to do is delay all they
have to do in their own mind is get
beyond august 31st because once they get
past august 31st once they get past
september 11th americans will just go
right back to sleep so the only question
is will we i think there's a 50 50 shot
we do maybe a better than even shot that
we do joe biden is banking on the
compliance and complacency of the
american people
and if that bet is correct frankly we
don't deserve to have the most powerful
country on planet earth we really know
because that takes some upkeep joe biden
in one do the upkeep he just wants you
to settle into the warm bath of
civilizational decay and slit your own
risks that is the goal here so will we
go along with it we're gonna find out in
pretty short order because that's the
actual plan forget about the contingency
plans that's the actual
big p plan from joe biden all right
we'll be back here later today with an
additional hour of content coming up
soon is the matt wall show airing at 1
30 pm eastern be sure to check it out
over at dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pawel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show